Rob Kardashian meets blac Chyna's family  I'm happy on sunday's episode of robin  china the couple flew to washington DC  to visit china's family at first rob was  hesitant to go it's the last thing I  want to be doing right now but once he  met his fiance's family he felt right at  home I feel like just throwing myself  into these uncomfortable situations is  what I gotta do in order to be happy and  get past everything the couple who's  expecting a baby girl next month had  dinner with a few of China's siblings  and her parents who hadn't spoken in  over 10 years oh then they all did what  any family would do together they headed  over to China's old stomping grounds  sensational strip club this crazy see my  dad and my mom hanging out together  we're all in a good place